Hey guys, I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop
Not too long ago,
We showed you how to take a simple recipe and mix it with liquid nitrogen
To make your own ice cream
It got me thinking that maybe there are some other things
You could mix liquid nitrogen with for other kinds of desserts
So I want to see if we can take soda and mix it with liquid nitrogen
To make our own slushies
This process I think is going to be pretty straightforward
We're gonna pour some of our soda into our bowl
And then slowly add liquid nitrogen while stirring until we get the consistency we want
Unless it doesn't work in which case this is going to be a really dumb video
I bet it'll work
It's liquid nitrogen
Eventually something will freeze
That's the goal
All right
Here we go
I want to fill this cup with our slushie once it's all frozen
So I'm just gonna use this cup to measure how much soda to put in
Should work about right
Let's just try splashing in a little bit of liquid nitrogen and stir it up
Spatula is a really good tool for keeping stuff off of the walls
But I think I want something that will do a little bit better of a job of mixing liquid nitrogen into the soda
Let's try the beater attachment to a hand mixer
I could use the hand mixer itself
But I think that might just be so vigorous that it splashes soda and liquid nitrogen everywhere
That's not my goal today, so I'll just use this by hand
And see it fills up with vapor very quickly unless I blow it all out
We're already starting to get some frozen slush along the sides of the bowl
Guess that's when I want my spatula
And you can see that. There is some slush already beginning to form down inside the soda
This is looking like it's gonna work really well
But you can see it's definitely gotten thicker it's to the point where I can sort of pile it on top of itself
Which I think is a very good sign
If you're getting pretty good results. Let's give this a taste and see how it's doing
That's really good, it tastes like a slushie... made from soda. It-
Almost all of the fizz is gone from this
Tastes really good though
Let's keep adding a little bit of liquid nitrogen and try and get it like a really stiff consistency
It's looking pretty good
There's nice and thick
Kind of like...
it's actually almost I think more of a snow cone consistency at this point
more snow cone less slushy
That's really good
It's nice and frozen easy to pick up with a spoon has the same taste in the soda like I said
I think it's lost all of the carbonation at this point
But it's quite good
Let's try and scoop it back out of the bowl into my cup and see if we can get a nice cup full slushy.
UH! Had so much liquid nitrogen on the bottom of our Bowl that it started to freeze some parts of it completely solid
Less slushy and more ice cube
I think that works very well
We now have a cup of slushy
Tastes great
The consistency is really nice like it's super...super smooth
I don't think I've ever had slushie where the consistency was that smooth almost creamy if ice can be creamy
Yeah I really like that if you've ever just tried freezing soda
Other than just exploding out of the can or bottle that it's in it sort of seems to separate a lot of the time so
You have just a chunk of
Almost unflavored ice and then sort of just syrup on the sides that didn't really freeze as much
This is very evenly mixed up so it really has the same taste as in soda
Maybe I'll try it with some other flavors
There you have it using soda and liquid nitrogen to make yourself some delicious frozen slushies it works very well
It goes very quickly and overall I think it's a fantastic result
I was a little bit surprised that it completely seems to get rid of all of the carbonation in the slushy
It starts out very fizzy of course since it's soda
But by the end, it's just got a smooth texture with no fizz to it
I'm wondering if it would work to make this same idea
But using dry ice to cool down the soda instead of liquid nitrogen
Maybe the dry ice that has been cooled down in the liquid nitrogen, so it's very powdery and extra cold
I think the dry ice would then help recarbanating soda as it froze it
Or maybe it would still be so cold that the carbon dioxide can't dissolve into it
I'm not sure
Thanks for joining us for this experiment today and remember to come get your hats, shirts and other cool merch at THEKINGOFRANDOM.COM
See you there
Hey guys Grant here
Just want to pop in with a quick update that the king of random brand is expanding
Nate's here because you wanted more DIY more variety more frequent videos and together
We're all making that happen
Thanks for your support